well goodbye angela european union
leaders have praised the german
chancellor today
she's attending what is likely to be her
final european union summit after 16
years in office in more than a hundred
more than a hundred
summits heads of governments have been
celebrating angela merkel's legacy
a fist bump to say goodbye
german chancellor angela merkel was
treated to a fond farewell as she
attended what is likely to be her final
european union summit as the leader of
germany
her departure comes at an uncertain time
for the eu
in her speech to the european council
merkel revealed she was worried about
the bloc's future
i am now leaving the european union in
my capacity as chancellor at a time when
there is cause for concerns
and just as in her first summit in 2005
there are critical issues on the agenda
we also have a range of unresolved
problems and the task facing my
successor is monumental
one of them is the question of the rule
of law but there is also the question of
migration which we have not yet resolved
between us
this is an area where we are of course
still vulnerable
over her many years in office merkel has
dealt with her fair share of challenges
too
from the eurozone crisis in 2009 to the
migrant crisis in 2015. her response to
these events has earned her a reputation
as a steady hand steering the eu through
troubled times
her calm and stoic brand of diplomacy
has drawn praise from around the world
it is a testament to your character that
you'd probably
enjoy working at a meeting of the
european council more than being the
center of attention like this
but i was proud to honor you with a
medal of freedom
for what your commitment to what the
alliance between the united states
germany
and europe can mean to the world
seen by many as the eu's de facto leader
and a bastion of democratic values
merkel's absence will be felt as the
block confronts the many challenges that
lie ahead of it
i want to go now to barbara
vasil on this is an auspicious occasion
isn't it barbara i mean we just saw
there the former u.s president barack
obama
angela merkel has been around so long
you've got an entire generation of of
young people who have only known a world
with angela merkel do you get the
feeling there at the summit that this
really is
a final goodbye
yeah the leaders here in brussels did
make this a momentous moment i mean they
were praising her to the rafters we saw
how barack obama got this so nicely
saying that she really hates being at
the center of attention but she had to
suffer through it today because they
were calling her a beacon of light they
were calling her a shining example a
haven of a piece of
calm and everything that they could
possibly think of and uh council
president xiaomi shell even came with
the fantastic uh
european council without american
european union without medical is like
the
paris without the eiffel tower it's like
rome without the vatican i mean could
you or ask for more they were really
falling all over themselves uh
applauding her and there there was a
strong feeling of course in the room
that this is the end of an era there is
not going to be coming somebody like her
along in the near future she was just
something very special yeah that that is
beautifully said barbara's standby i
want to talk about the business now that
had to be done in brussels at this
summit european union leaders have spent
the last two days tackling a list of
mounting challenges for the european
union a new wave of migration coming
across europe's borders has sparked
debate between countries some leaders
want to build more walls to control
migration others are hoping for
diplomatic solutions
this is what some want the future of eu
migration policy to look like at the
border between greece and turkey there
is a massive steel barrier with one job
stop migrants and refugees from entering
europe
at the eu summit in brussels leaders
gathered and some demanded greater
measures along the block's external
borders
building a wall i don't really like the
sound of it but we need a strong robust
border protection
after hours of talks the lithuanian
president said the council knew what a
quote frontline country felt like
we cannot solve the secondary migration
problem without the solving primarily
migration and this primarily migration
is at our border so lukashenko regime
now
will see that european union is able to
react is able to take the decisions
and is ready to defend itself
this is what the lithuanian president is
referring to a group of migrants in
poland who have moved through belarus
across the border
the situation is serious poland has
ramped up border protection but security
forces are accused of conducting violent
pushbacks
the alleged actions of bella russian
president alexander lukashenka can be
felt here in brussels
eu leaders often not on the same page
when it comes to migration
did agree on several points at this
summit including this a statement
condemning all hybrid attacks at the
eu's borders and promising to respond
commission was also tasked to propose
changes to combat future challenges that
they say are just a matter of time
belarus as we're observing now is
looking at opening new routes
it has offered further visa waivers to
additional third countries
and we will continue our engagement with
these countries to limit this state
sponsored smuggling
despite these quick fixes commission
president fonder line reiterated the
need for a common migration and asylum
policy
fences alone won't solve the problem
and barbara you know we have
you and i we've talked many times many
many eu summits where angela merkel was
doing her best to get all member states
of the eu to agree to a common migration
policy
and she couldn't do it
what does what does it mean for her
successor or is the likelihood of a
unified migration policy now small or
without miracle
it might be just about the same because
this was the one big task that eluded
her she tried again and again there were
special summits late night talks
everything
but it never led to anything because
there's too much emotion involved
nationalism populism xenophobia fear all
these things that sort of drive
countries apart instead of pulling
together and saying uh we need to solve
this i mean they talk about solving this
together but they never really meant it
and it's going to stay like this in the
foreseeable future now the easy part was
of course today to get around condemning
alexander lukashenko i mean that is more
or less
the given thing
they're also going to be more sanctions
against him that
they're going to try to turn screw a bit
more
and they will try to talk to the third
countries where these migrants come from
iraq partly the kurdish
area in turkey and other areas where
they have partners they can talk to and
say can we discourage people from coming
can we stop airlines transporting these
people and so that is the solution
they're looking for what they hardly
talked about was the dire humanitarian
situation on the border and what to do
with the migrants once they're there
once they're in europe how to distribute
them that was as unsolved as ever
our brussels correspondent barbara basil
with the ladies tonight barbara as
always thank you
you